[Music]
we took walks at night
sometimes we could see venus above us
it was the shepherd's star and the star
of love
[Music]
one of the reasons i enjoy acting i
think quite shy really
i mean i can be quite shy and what
acting does it allows you to take on the
role of something else to get rid of
your own anxieties
just before i came to america with my
friend she gave me um
a copy of just kids it pulls you in i
think it kind of takes you straight into
that time of rebellion and expression
and feminism
kind of anger
i feel like you're transported to a time
that doesn't exist and it's nice to
stand still and just
kind of watch it however there may be
but i felt safe no one noticed me
i could move freely i wasn't kin to
these people
but because of the free-floating
atmosphere i could roam within it
i had faith i sensed no danger in the
city
i was happy just being free
and it was a story of just these these
two people and these two lovers just
being together and discovering and kind
of choosing our
you know they didn't really know what
they were doing or how they were going
to get by
but you know just knowing that's all
they wanted to do
you know having no reassurance or no
backup plan just expressing themselves
throughout in love
he was searching consciously or
unconsciously for himself
he was in a fresh state of
[Music]
transformation
[Music]
i had nothing to offer a fee for didn't
fear men on the prowl
i wasn't of interest to anyone
[Music]
if you want to do something enough they
can't they can't be a backup plan
you know you kind of can't just do it
and do it truthfully with desired
[Music]
you